i mean if i went again because the last
time i went snowboarding was like
[ __ ] like six years ago i would
definitely get a helmet just because
like
my body's not used to it right yeah i
didn't really give [ __ ] i was with these
guys on like
like the green slopes and blue slopes
and i was like yeah [ __ ]
it's fine but then like if i went down
like i i took uh you went down to like a
black diamond well yeah so i took mackie
down a black dude
i i was like oh okay so everyone
everyone had left and then it was mackie
was the one calling them a coward and i
was like all right it's time
let's go and just let's go and do a real
one and there's a double black diamond
which i wanted to do but so to clarify
like black diamond is like the hardest
type of course it's just like double
black diamond which is like the most
extreme
yeah and i couldn't convince him to do
that because i think he was like oh no
i'm good but i'm not like that i was
like okay i love how like
something about snowboarding just turns
every guy
into a dude bro you know what i mean
like yeah i can just imagine like when
god did that clean turn and
kind of was like
what is it about it that like turns you
into like a lab
when i'm bringing my friends my biggest
worry is that they will
hate it from falling over too much and
they don't want to do it yeah yeah
because then i'm like what
i can't bring my friends again like yeah
you can't go we can't go to the alps you
know we can't go to italy
drink espressos then hit the slopes yeah
have a few babies in germany and hit the
apps you know they can't do
that that's what i want to do so and
then i was like yeah
it's just the boys now just me and
mackie i'm gonna take him down to black
and so i meant i i found one where that
i he definitely didn't want to do i was
like come on
cost it i'll be fine i'll be fine
knowing monkey you can't say no right
yeah he was like ah he's like i wanted
to do a hard sword but like not this
hard i'm like i'll be fine
literally like this slope you can't see
the bottom of it like you can't see over
it
until you start going down yeah it's
like that steep yeah
and then when i started going on it i
was like oh i think this is closed
because it hadn't been treated at all it
was all ice it was all steep ice
like crevices and like it was so steep
that when you would go off a little bit
you would just fall
and yeah crevice right nice
it was it took all my [ __ ] energy to
get down this thing without falling over
that's [ __ ] terrifying i was
absolutely
exhausted i don't really get tired when
i go on like blue or red ones because i
don't really have to use that much work
kind of crazy but on the really tough
ones the amount you're turning
you have to constantly turn and throw
your body where it doesn't the board is
like no no we can't turn on this it's
too steep yeah yeah
you have to force it otherwise you're
going too fast so i'm like i'm like
knackered
and then i look up and i see maggie just
he gets up [ __ ] pop like falls over
gets up
falls over gets up falls over i was like
oh my god meleen's gonna [ __ ] kill me
oh my god connor's going to kill him
yeah that's gonna cause that was on the
second day right yeah
yeah cause like uh we we went our
separate ways on the second day because
i you know i woke up felt like
everything was aching everything felt
like [ __ ] but
i was just like no i'm i'm a still guy
i'm sorry you're still pumped
i'm just i'm still pumped because i
really really wanted a second day so i
was like oh
easy fight through the pain what it's
just just a bit of muscle ache right you
can get through a bit of muscle ache
so these guys go off to like a
completely different course yeah
yeah there's like two sides of the mouth
yeah there was like two sides of the
mouth so these guys are gonna completely
different course and i'm just like
great i'll just be left to my own
devices and by the end of this day
i'm going to conquer this beginner hill
right because i i felt like
so uh sydney had given up by then
um and everyone else was on this other
hill and on the second day it was
actually like
almost empty compared to the first day
because the first day was like i think
like it was like a sunday wasn't it or
like a saturday
ah yeah it must have been it was it was
like a public holiday all right
and the second day wasn't a public
holiday so like the slopes were like
almost empty conditions as well there's
like a [ __ ] ton of snow and it was like
perfectly clear oh no sun was out it was
like perfect yes nice
good so i so i get up to the beginning
of slope on the second day everything
aching as [ __ ] and i'm just like
it's fine all i need to do is like
tumble once and i'll just like
fly through the pain and you know get it
get it over with so like
i go down right uh i go i start going
down this beginning he'll get further
than i
did yesterday because i gotten more used
to it yeah and then i tumble and i was
like
all right i i'm like you know i expect
this
but like i tumbled and i landed with my
head like downhill
so like so like i was i was like
downhill like this yeah
right and um and then i i quickly
realized
oh how do i get up
right because because my neck my neck
muscles
were not working at the point so i i i
could not lift my neck to go
like that i was not only like lift i was
i was lifting it not only like
you know even even when i was like
perfectly flat
it was hard enough to lift my neck up no
i was going against the hill as well to
lift my neck up
so i quickly realized that i couldn't
lift my neck up and i quickly realized
how heavy my gear that i was wearing
what i would do is just add if i'm face
down i just bring my board
i do like a flip you can do a flip but
you can also kind of just like turn your
body around like shimmy
if you want to be faster you can just
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah stamp it into
this yeah i i i did not have enough ab
strength at that time
that's how much like that's how much
like my everything was aching yeah of
course yeah i kind of realized quickly
i was in a little bit of a little bit of
a pickle because i didn't know
how i was going to get up with all this
heavy gear so
um what i try doing is just like slowly
shimming
shut uh what was that shimmy shimmy like
my body
to be like horizontal or something where
i could get up um
that took that took ages
i must have been there for like 40
minutes right because no one helped you
no no that's that's that's the point
that's why i was there for like a good
20 minutes and i'd gotten around like
i'd say
about 20 degrees
because if i saw someone upside down i
would go overboard
so after about so after about uh so
after about uh
20 degrees like someone someone skis
down and says
are you okay do you need any help and
i'm just like
no i'm okay i think i got this
so he goes okay um and he offers me a
hand and so
um i get up and uh i you know he helps
me sit back
up um and so i see i sit back up
he goes back over and i'm like okay i
got this um
i try shimmering a bit more slip like my
my body slips a bit and i'm like back
back in my back right and i never
i i had never known how it felt to be
like you know you know when you see like
a tortoise on their back
yeah they can't get back up that's
exactly how i felt
and so after another 20 minutes i
finally get to the point where
my feet is like my i'm feet first
down the hill and i'm just like [ __ ]
this i take off the snowboard and i walk
and
i walk the rest of the way down there i
am not going through that experience
again i would do like whatever it takes
to not take the board off i'm like i
would do
honestly that's what that's what i
thought but i'm just like it took me
literally
40 minutes hate admitting defeat until
yeah there's nothing sadder than just
like
walking down while everyone's just
shooting past you right yeah
it was it was a depressing but you have
to if you have to do it it's crazy like
everyone
snowballs in japan it's really weird in
europe everyone skis
yeah yeah japan yeah for some reason no
one wears helmets no
no one wears helmets it's scary yeah
it's and like the rental place didn't
even offer it
no that's i it's like it's like an
option you have to ask for it's nuts and
i was like
you don't offer helmets yeah cause i got
like the rental pack which was like
apparently like the all-inclusive pack
and they just yeah clearly not all yeah
you know even like professionals wear
helmets you know what i mean like
exactly but you never know what could
happen right because uh [ __ ] uh what
was it michael schumacher fell and hit a
rock didn't he and then he's like
he's in a like vegetative state now i
think is he and he's like a really
experienced skier yeah yeah
and he just hit a rock yeah i don't know
i guess i guess no
yeah i guess nobody told me and i i wish
i
turned up and i'm like oh god they don't
have helmets
i mean i mean i wish i had worn a helmet
so i could go the second day without
feeling like it would help with your
neck as well because yeah you'd have you
wouldn't be like
i wouldn't be like [ __ ] would it or
would it just be like extra weight on
your head
oh god because i feel like that extra
like distance you go that the helmet off
like cushions oh that's true it
definitely helps yeah
also though dude skiing and then being
able to get like a fat ramen or a curry
not damn that's good oh yeah
like that onsen you go to after a full
day of snowboarding is the best [ __ ]
feeling yeah
it is the best sleeping in this place
was just like a view of like
it was like an outdoor onset where you
just viewed the
mountains nice and like refurbished it
all as well yeah yeah [ __ ] could feel
like the snow coming down
take me back man take me back no this
old hopefully i'll be able to join you
guys this year
yeah oh yeah hell yeah i do i want to
ski so god damn much
like seasons i haven't done nearly as
much as i wanted to when i came here
yeah i
[ __ ] did again like i haven't gone
snowboarding or skiing in like five
years yeah and it's supposed to be like
some of the best skiing
in the world in uh in japan yeah some
some of the slopes i worked on is
[ __ ] insane i would just want an
experience where i'm not on my
ass for literally 90 of the day that's
that that would that would be a cool
experience yeah
like also just after you after you're
all like sore you know you all go to the
onsen then you go for the meal and you
get a bunch of beers oh it's so good
yeah yeah after ski beer or snowboarding
yeah